ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen in
einer Kirche der Zeugen Jehovas sind
gestern Abend 8 Menschen erschossen
worden im Hamburger Stadtteil Alsterdorf
mehrere weitere Menschen wurden schwer
verletzt in wenigen Minuten beginnt dazu
eine Pressekonferenz der Behörden in
Hamburg hier sehen wir das Bild aus dem
Polizeipräsidium und wir werden das live
übertragen hier bei ZDF heute live wie
immer gerne eure Fragen und Kommentare
in die Kommentare oder an die
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF heute -
live.at zdf.de wir behalten im Auge ob
die Damen und Herren schon bereit sind
für die Pressekonferenz noch sehen wir
tut sich dort nichts deshalb schalten
wir zu unserem Korrespondenten Ralf
Zimmermann von Siefert der für uns im
Polizeipräsidium ist Ralf was ist denn
der aktuelle Stand der Erkenntnisse
also offizielle hat die Polizei bisher
wenig bekannt gegeben deshalb jetzt auch
diese Pressekonferenz übrigens auch mit
dem Hamburger Innensenator an die grote
also ein Fall der Hamburg wirklich sehr
erschüttert bekannt ist man weiß bisher
von der Tat dass sie gegen 21 Uhr
begangen wurde ein einzelner Täter so
ist zu vermuten das wird jetzt alles
gleich bestätigt in dieser
Pressekonferenz hier vermutlich ist in
ein Haus eingedrungen dass von den
Zeugen Jehovas betrieben wird wo eine
ein Gebetsraum es gibt aber auch weitere
Räume wo es wöchentliche Zusammenkünfte
gibt und so eine wöchentliche
Zusammenkunft von über 30 Personen in
diesem Gebäude hat wohl gestern Abend
stattgefunden und da ist dieser Täter
rein gegen 21 Uhr und hat sofort das
Feuer eröffnet mit was für einer Waffe
wissen wir auch noch nicht aber
jedenfalls in vier Feuerstößen hat er
mehrere Personen getötet und auch
verletzt zusätzlich es ist von
mindestens sechs Personen die Rede
möglicherweise ist sind es auch noch
einen oder zwei mehr und es ist es gibt
mehrere Schwerverletzte die in
Krankenhäuser gekommen sind wie viel
davon den Lebensgefahr schweben wissen
wir auch noch nicht genau und dann ist
als die Polizei kam um 21 Uhr etwa hat
es eine einzelnen Schuss noch mal
gegeben in einem der oberen Stockwerke
dieses Hauses und dann ist die Polizei
dort nach oben gestürmt und hat dort
einen einzelnen Mann gefunden Tod auch
am Boden liegend vermutlich das ist
jetzt ein bisschen Spekulation noch auch
das wird gleich bestätigt hat der Täter
dieser einzelne Täter sich selbst
gerichtet nach dieser schrecklichen Tat
die dort in diesem Haus gegangen wurde
im Stadtteil Alsterdorf so viel weiß man
also bis zu diesem Moment gondola Koch
fast noch einmal auch das zusammen was
man zusammentragen konnte
am Tag nach den tödlichen Schüssen
während einer Veranstaltung der Zeugen
Jehovas laufen die Ermittlungen der
Polizei auf Hochtouren die blutige Tat
im Hamburger Stadtteil Alsterdorf
geschah gestern Abend gegen 21 Uhr eine
Spezialeinheit der Polizei ist zufällig
in der Nähe und in wenigen Minuten am
Tatort
die Polizeibeamten die dort reingegangen
sind haben dann auch Personen
aufgefunden die möglicherweise die
Schusswaffe schwer verletzt und
teilweise auch tödlich verletzt worden
sind
acht Menschen werden in dieser Nacht
durch Schüsse getötet zahlreiche
verletzt die Umgebung wird weiträumig
abgesperrt und die Anwohner werden durch
eine warn-app aufgefordert ihre Häuser
nicht zu verlassen ein Handy-Video soll
den mutmaßlichen Täter zeigen bevor er
in das Gebäude dringt und die Schüsse
abfeuert ist irgendwann ins Gebäude
reingegangen durch das Fenster was er
sich zuvor verschlossen hat und dann gab
es ganz lange keine Schüsse auch als der
Titel drin war
nur als die Polizei da war ca 4 Minuten
danach gab es nur noch einen einzigen
Schluss dieser Schuss soll im oberen
Stockwerk abgegeben worden sein die
Beamten die sich zu dieser Zeit im
Gebäude befinden entdecken kurz darauf
die Leiche eines Mannes die Polizei geht
davon aus dass es sich dabei um den
Täter handelt er soll ein ehemaliges
Mitglied der Zeugen Jehovas sein nähere
Informationen über Täter und Motiv gibt
die Hamburger Polizei zur Stunde bekannt
tja und zwar ganz genau jetzt wir sehen
die Bilder von der Pressekonferenz die
Herren dort neben Platz wir sehen an die
grote den Innensenator der Stadt Hamburg
Polizeipräsident Ralf Martin Meyer sehen
wir hier den Leiter der Schutzpolizei
Matthias tresk der ist dabei und auch
ein Vertreter der Bundesanwaltschaft
Ralf Peter anders und wir hören rein wie
die Erkenntnisse sind zu der Blut Tat
gestern Abend in Hamburg in der
Religionsgemeinschaft der Zeugen Jehovas
dazu begrüße ich den Innensenator an die
grote der einleitende und einordnende
Worte vornehmen wird der
Polizeipräsident Ralf Martin Meyer und
der Leiter der Schutzpolizei Matthias
tresk werden zum Einsatz Geschehen
Ausführungen machen und für die
Informationen die den Bereich der
Ermittlungen betreffen werden dr Ralf
Peter anders und der Leiter der Status
ist Thomas hat soweit Auskünfte gegeben
für abschließende O-Töne das vielleicht
noch mal stehen nach den Fragen der
Senator und der Polizeipräsident zur
Verfügung dazu werden
machen weil das sonst in zeitlichen
Rahmen springen würde ich übergebe jetzt
das Wort an den Inseln
gestern Abend
gestern Abend hat sich in unserer Stadt
ein
entsetzliches Verbrechen zugetragen dem
sieben Menschen zum Opfer gefallen sind
acht weitere wurden zum Teil schwer
verletzt
wir
verspüren ein Gefühl tiefer inständiger
Trauer und
fühlen mit den Angehörigen der Opfer
denken an die Verletzten und hoffen dass
alle überleben und es Ihnen schnell
besser geht
es ist eine grauenvolle Tat es ist auch
das werden wir noch hören eine sehr
grausame Tat
wir haben in Hamburg
ja auch schon einiges
erlebt aber eine Amok Tat ein
Tötungsdelikt dieser
Dimension das kannten wir
bisher nicht sowas hat man
im Fernsehen gesehen es ist woanders
passiert und mochte sich nicht
vorstellen dass es auch mal unsere Stadt
treffen könnte
das ist jetzt passiert das ist die
schlimmste Straftat das schlimmste
Verbrechen in der jüngeren Geschichte
unserer Stadt
und
wir haben es mit allerhöster
Wahrscheinlichkeit dem sehr sehr
schnellen und entschlossenen Eingreifen
der Einsatzkräfte der Polizei zu
verdanken
dass hier nicht noch mehr Opfer zu
beklagen sind
die Tat ereignete sich gegen 21 Uhr der
Straße der Bürger im Stadtteil Groß
Borstel in einem Gebäude das von der
Gemeinde der Zeugen Jehovas genutzt wird
während die Gemeinde sich dort
versammelt hatte
um 21 Uhr ging die ersten Notrufe ein
zum Teil aus dem Gebäude
um 21 Uhr also vier Minuten später waren
erste Kräfte vor Ort und um 21 Uhr neun
aber bereits
haben die Kräfte der USA
Einheit die
robuster anders ausgerüstet ist in
besonders gefährdungs geneigten
Situationen immer schnell vor Ort sein
soll bevor die
Spezialeinheiten dann alarmiert werden
können die waren schon um 21 Uhr dort
haben sich um 21:11 Uhr gewaltsam
Zutritt zum Gebäude verschafft und haben
damit das tat Geschehen nach allem was
wir jetzt wissen unterbrochen da haben
Täter und Opfer voneinander getrennt
und wir können davon ausgehen dass sie
damit
vielen Menschen das Leben gerettet haben
der Täter ist bei Eintreffen der
Einsatzkräfte ins erste Obergeschoss
geflüchtet
und hat sich dann später dort selbst
getötet so dass wir insgesamt von acht
Toten sprechen
es sind anschließend
weitere Kräfte
alarmiert worden herangeführt worden es
ist halt ein Großeinsatz natürlich der
Hamburger Polizei stattgefunden aber
auch der Feuerwehr
Hilfsorganisationen
Kriseninterventionsteams eine ist das
Einsatzkonzept das vorbereitete
Einsatzkonzept für amoklagen ausgelöst
worden und das ist dann sehr
professionell und umfassend
gestern Abend
abgearbeitet worden es gab ja noch
Unsicherheiten ob es möglicherweise
einen zweiten Täter gibt das hat sich ja
dann nicht bewahrheitet man hat sich
sehr intensiv und sehr schnell dann auch
um die Verletzten gekümmert und auch um
all diejenigen die dann
psychische Unterstützung gebraucht haben
wir haben auch eine nicht unerhebliche
Zahl von Einsatzkräften von Polizei und
Feuerwehr die unterstützt werden müssen
die Angehörigen Augenzeugen Beteiligte
an dieser Tat man mag sich kaum
vorstellen was Menschen durchgemacht
haben die unmittelbar dabei waren bei
diesem Angriff
den Toten befand sich befindet sich im
übrigen auch ein
ungeborenes Kind im Alter von sieben
Monaten das im Mutterleib getroffen
wurde
von meiner Seite deshalb an dieser
Stelle zunächst einmal ein großer
ausdrücklicher Dank an alle
Einsatzkräfte die gestern diesen sehr
sehr schweren
extremen Einsatz bewältigt haben mit
großer Umsicht Professionalität die sehr
schnell vor Ort waren und ich glaube
Polizei nicht das was man in einer
solchen Lage dann tun kann getan haben
schnell Sicherheit und wiederhergestellt
haben
für den
weiteren
ja für die weiteren Darstellung zur
Ablauf des Einsatzes was tat Geschehen
bisher bisher wissen würde ich einmal an
den Einsatzleiter des gestrigen Abends
und schafft der Schutzpolizei Ihre
Adresse weitergeben und dann hören wir
noch auch das was wir über Täter Motiv
Lage und so weiter mögliche weitere
Erkenntnisse schon haben im weiteren
Verlauf
ja schön danke gut guten Tag meine Damen
und Herren Herr grote hat mich schon
vorgestellt Matthias tresk im Alltag
Leiter der Hamburger Schutzpolizei
gestern Abend Polizei
gesamtpolizeiführer der amoklage wie wir
sie dann auch von der Konzeption her
relativ schnell bezeichnet haben
ich möchte noch mal ergänzend den Ablauf
für Sie
kompakt
darstellen
21:04 Uhr hatten wir sowohl bei der
Feuerwehr als auch in der Polizei
Einsatzzentrale insgesamt 47 Notrufe
die sehr deutlich und klar auf ein
Geschehen hinwiesen sehr dramatisch das
Schüsse fallen im Gebäude debüge 17 das
gilt das Gebäude der Gemeinde Zeugen
Jehovas
was natürlich sofort zu entsprechenden
größeren Einsatz waren Maßnahmen Seins
der Polizei und der Feuerwehr geführt
hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt 21:04 Uhr sagte
ich gerade wussten wir noch nicht
detailliert um was es sich handelt
wir hatten wie Herr Senator grote schon
sagte zu diesem Zeitpunkt Gott sei Dank
die Einheit USA das sind Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Beweissicherung und
Festnahme Hundertschaft der
Bereitschaftspolizei
Landesbereitschaftspolizei Hamburg in
Dienst gerade noch es war ein
glücklicher Zufall dass diese
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sich hier zu
diesem Zeitpunkt gerade in Alsterdorf
befanden und wie Sie wissen ist der
Tatort in unmittelbarer Nähe zu unserem
Standort hier so dass diese Kräfte ganz
schnell am Einsatzort waren durch ihre
entsprechende Ausbildung die sie
genossen haben gerade für Amok und
terrorlagen haben diese Kollegen mit
ihrer Ausrüstung aber auch mit ihrer
Ausbildung sehr schnell die Lage
antizipiert und erkannt dass kein
abwarten mehr
hinzunehmen ist und haben sofort
versucht sich Zugang zum Gebäude zu
verschaffen das gelang nicht so einfach
die Tür war verschlossen die Kollegen
haben sich mittels Schusswaffe indem sie
in die Scheibe geschossen haben
Zugriff auf die Türklinke des Gebäudes
verschafft konnten dann die Tür zum
Gebäude öffnen und haben sich dann
Zugang ins Gebäude verschafft bevor sie
eindringen konnten ins Gebäude konnten
sie permanent Schüsse aus dem Gebäude
hören
beim Eindringen ins Gebäude nahm die
ersten Einsatzkräfte dieser use
Unterstützungseinheit der beweis- und
Festnahme Hundertschaft der
Landesbereitschaftspolizei einen
potenziellen Täter so nahmen sie in wahr
eine Person die vor ihm flüchtete war
wie diese Person in den ersten Stock
lief in den Augen der Polizeibeamten
flüchtete so dass die Polizeibeamten
dann taktisch die weiteren
Räumlichkeiten dieses Gebäudes betraten
feststellen dass eine größere Zahl von
Menschen sich in einem Saal befanden sie
sahen bereits erste Menschen am Boden
liegend und eine Person wie gesagt in
den ersten Stock laufend die Kräfte
haben dann sofort nachgesetzt und haben
sehr schnell festgestellt dass es sich
bei der Person die in den ersten Stock
gelaufen ist um eine Person mit einer
ausgestatteten Schusswaffe handelte wir
wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht so viel
nur dass eine Person am Boden lag leblos
mit einer tödlichen Schussverletzung
neben sich eine
Faustformel liegend oben keine weiteren
Person so dass sie der Senator Brote
eben schon andeutete sich für uns im
Nachgang die Situation der Art darstellt
dass durch das sehr schnelle Handeln und
Eindringen der Kräfte in das Gebäude
eine Trennung zwischen
Besuchern der Veranstaltung der Zeugen
Jehovas in dem Gebäude und dem Täter
stattgefunden hat die Kräfte schildern
dass sie Druck offensichtlich auf den
Täter ausgeübt haben und das ist genau
das was wir in solchen
einsatzkonzeptionen wollen sofortiges
Handeln muss den Täter möglichst in
seinem Handlungsspielraum beengen einen
eng isolieren um möglichst schnell
weitere Opfer vermeiden zu können das
ist nach derzeitigen Sachstand gelungen
vielleicht zum Ablauf dessen was wir an
Täter handeln bis wir wissen ohne der
Kriminalpolizei vorweg greifen zu wollen
bevor der Täter in das Gebäude selbst
eindrang ist von der Nordseite des
Gebäudes wenn sie sich die Straße die
Bürger vorstellen dass er rechtzeitig
anders Gebäude herangetreten während in
diesem Gemeindesaal im Erdgeschoss eine
Veranstaltung der Gemeinde mit
ca 50 Gästen stattgefunden hat dieser
Täter hat dann bevor er auf das Gebäude
agiert hat eine auf dem dortigen
Parkplatz befindliche Frau die mit einem
Fahrzeug rangierte wahrgenommen hat auf
dieses Fahrzeug in dem sich eine Frau
befand geschossen wir haben derzeit zehn
Einschuss auf dieses Fahrzeug das die
Frau konnte leicht verletzt mit dem Auto
flüchten hat sich denn unmittelbar
danach von einem anderen Ort bei der
Polizei gemeldet danach hat der Täter
mit der Schusswaffe durch die Scheibe
auf die Veranstaltung eingewirkt ist im
weiteren Verlauf durch das Fenster in
das Gebäude eingedrungen und der
permanenten Schusswaffen gebraucht
näheres wir terrazinieren dazu weit in
gleich sagen wie viel Magazine wird da
insgesamt gefunden haben unsere Anzahl
der Schüsse hat und der permanenten
Schusswaffen gebraucht das Gebäude
weiterhin betreten und ist und jetzt
füge ich die beiden Bilder wieder
zusammen erst durch das Eindringen der
ersten Polizeibeamten praktisch von den
Menschen getrennt worden so dass wir
eine
Zahl die um bei 20 Personen unverletzt
aus dem Gebäude
retten konnten und auch die Menschen die
verletzt überlebt haben rechnen wir den
Ereignissen und dem Einschalten der
Polizeibeamten zu dass wir also jetzt
mit Sachstand jetzt sagen können dass
sofortige Handeln hat vielen Menschen
das Leben gerettet wir hatten dann die
Situation
dass wir zunächst nicht wussten ist der
Täter alleine vor Ort gewesen das ist
können Sie sich vorstellen sehr
schwierige Lage das einzuschätzen die
eigentlich überschlagen sich sie haben
unfassbar viele Informationen die sich
auch nicht unbedingt immer decken die
auch nicht immer zusammenpassen und wir
gingen in der ersten Zeit ja erstmal der
der Idee nach wir haben oben einen
Menschen mit einer Schusswaffe tödlich
verletzt am Boden liegen gefunden so
dass wir erstmal herausfinden mussten
haben wir die Sicherheit durch
Zeugenaussagen dass es sich
möglicherweise um die Täter handelt das
verdichtete sich zunehmen äh so dass wir
zunächst erstmal hoffen von einem Täter
nur ausgehen zu können bis sich dann
folgen
Videoaufnahmen von der daneben liegenden
Tankstelle und uns den Hinweis gaben
dass es möglicherweise zwei Personen vor
Ort gegeben haben könnte das hat für uns
die polizeilichen Maße natürlich noch
mal erheblich dynamischer gestaltet die
sich vorstellen sehen vorstellen konnten
nachdem wir wussten dass das Gebäude
durch die Kräfte sicher betreten und
auch sicher gemacht wurde dass wir im
Gebäude keine weiteren Täter mehr hatten
die Rettungskräfte ihre Arbeit
nachkommen konnten war die Frage haben
wir außerhalb des Gebäudes in ihren
Umfeld oder wo auch immer in der Stadt
einen zweiten Täter herumlaufen das war
die Herausforderung dann der nächsten
Stunden wir haben dann umfassend
alarmiert sind der Einsatzkonzeption
Amok in der Struktur gefolgt und haben
dann zunächst auch mal die Frage eruiert
haben wir weitere Gebäude die der
Gemeinde der Zeugen Jehovas in Hamburg
zuzurechnen sind haben sofort Kräfte
entsand haben geguckt ob laufende
Veranstaltung sind wenn ja hätten wir
sie mit sofortigen Objektschutz besetzt
haben da aber keinerlei Feststellungen
gehabt es blieb unklar keinerlei
Fahndungsmaßnahmen haben uns weitere
Erkenntnisse gebracht und erste weiteren
Fortgang die Videoaufzeichnung die dann
ausgewählt von plus die Zeugen die wir
mittlerweile die unverletzten Zeugen die
wir dann über die Betreuungssituation in
eine erste Befragung durch die
Kriminalpolizei bringen konnten haben
uns dann im Verlaufe der Stunden die
Sicherheit gegeben dass wir dann
tatsächlich wohl nur von einem Täter am
Ende ausgehen durften
vielleicht eine Besonderheit die ihnen
mal deutlich machen kann mit welchen
Schwierigkeiten man unter Home Zeitdruck
unter Home Informationsfluss zu zu tun
hat die es besagte Video von einem
Zeugen dass sehr eindrucksvoll war
konnten wir uns sehr früh dann angucken
und ich glaube jeder von ihnen wäre am
ersten Moment auf die Idee gekommen das
ist tatsächlich zwei Personen an diesem
Gebäude gab die seitlich versucht haben
am Gebäude auf die Veranstaltung zu
agieren bis man beim weiteren betrachten
und genauen auswirken feststellen musste
dass das ein schattensystem das war das
in der Dunkelheit in der Situation macht
ihn glaube ich deutlich mit welchen
Schwierigkeiten man unter homezeichnung
zu tun hat wenn die Frage zu beantworten
ist haben wir erneut irgendwo gefahren
die jederzeit hochkommen können und
haben wir Menschen leben die weiterhin
gefahren sind und wie können wir dem
möglichst zügig und kompakt begegnen
insgesamt
darf ich feststellen dass aus Sicht der
Schutzpolizei insbesondere erste
einsatzphase
eigentlich so verlaufen ist wie man sie
unter den tragischen Bedingungen dann
auch nur erhoffen kann nämlich sehr
zügig die Kräfte die man braucht vor Ort
sehr zügig handlungsfähig gewesen sehr
schnell in das Gebäude reingekommen sehr
schnell die Menschen dann auch aus dem
Gebäude reingebracht und den
Rettungskräften das darf man auch nicht
unterschätzen die Möglichkeit gegeben
dann auch den verletzten möglichst zügig
medizinische Hilfe zu kommen ist ein
Faktor den man nicht unterschätzen kann
wenn es sich um schwere
schlussverletzung da handelt
das wäre von meiner Seite zunächst
erstmal alles wir haben
neben den eben erwähnten Toten die wir
zu beklagen haben nach derzeitigen
Sachstand acht weitere Verletzte davon
vier schwer und wir haben auf
polizeilicher Seite natürlich auch eine
nicht unerhebliche Anzahl von Kollegen
die betreut werden müssen auch in diesem
Zusammenhang möchte ich Ihnen einen
Umstand
zur Kenntnis geben der sowohl bei der
Feuerwehr als auch bei der Polizei
stattgefunden hat dort hat es eben auch
Anrufe aus dem Gebäude in der
kurzsituation gegeben bei unseren
Mitarbeitern und die haben dann während
des Anrufes wahrnehmen müssen dass diese
Anrufer nicht mehr in der Lage war
weiter zu sprechen weil vermutlich durch
den Täter bekämpft oder ermordet muss
man besser sagen das war natürlich für
die Kollegen auch keine einfache
Situation letztlich kann ich aber sagen
sie haben alle hochprofessionell und
sehr schnell gehandelt so dass wir
zumindest
an vielen Stellen helfen konnten das
wäre es von meiner Seite für den ersten
Part danke schön
ja guten Tag mein Name ist Ralf anders
ich bin der Leiter der
Staatsanwaltschaft Hamburg und ich darf
Ihnen ein paar Dinge ein paar Mitteilung
machen zu dem Ablauf des gestrigen
Abends der gestrigen Nachtsicht der
Strafverfolgungsbehörde
Staatsanwaltschaft vorweg darf ich Ihnen
sagen dass auch im Namen der
Staatsanwaltschaft Hamburg ich Ihnen
hier meine Bestürzung und Trauer
mitteilen darf unsere Gedanken sind bei
den Verletzten den Hinterbliebenen ihren
Familien und ihren Freunden
in der gestrigen Nachbarin sehr früh
Vertreter der Staatsanwaltschaft am
Tatort ein Beamter der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Hamburg war
vertreten und zwei Kollegen aus der Mord
Abteilung der Staatsanwaltschaft Hamburg
es war wie wir gehört haben ein
dynamisches Geschehen es war auch noch
nicht auszuschließen dass das Geschehen
vielleicht ein terroristischen
Hintergrund hatte so dass sehr früh auch
Kontakt aufgenommen wurde zu Behörde des
Generalbundesanwalts in Karlsruhe
umgegebenen falls dieses Verfahren
dorthin abgeben zu können
aufgrund der Unklarheit ob noch ein
zweiter oder sogar ein dritter Täter mit
beteiligt sein könnte wurde um
00:30 Uhr seitens der Staatsanwaltschaft
auf Gefahren verzugte Durchsuchungen der
Wohnung des Täters angeordnet bei dieser
Durchsuchung der Wohnung sind
verschiedene Dinge aufgefunden worden
insbesondere 15 geladene Magazine
jeweils mit 15 Patronen und auch weitere
vier Schachteln Munition und insgesamt
weiteren 200 Patronen
weitere
als erwarte die beschlagnahmen werden
konnten waren Laptops Smartphones und
deren Auswertung jetzt natürlich noch
andauert das heißt die notwendigen
strafprozessoren Maßnahmen sind von der
Staatsanwaltschaft in dieser Nacht
sofort durchgeführt worden nach jetzigen
Erkenntnissen gibt es keinen weiteren
Täter die Gefahrenlage ist insoweit im
Griff und es gibt auch keine Hinweise
auf einen terroristischen Hintergrund so
dass die Zuständigkeit des
Generalbundesanwalts nicht gegeben ist
der Täter ist bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
Hamburg nicht bekannt wir haben gegen
ihn vorher keine verfahren wir haben
auch gegen ihn keine Strafanzeigen bei
der Staatsanwaltschaft Hamburg vorliegen
das einzige was uns vorliegt sind
Strafanzeigen die wiederum von ihm an
die Staatsanwaltschaft in der bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft eingereicht wurde
wegen des angeblichen Verdachts des
Betrugs und diesen jedenfalls einer von
diesen Strafanzeigen wird noch
nachgegangen werden soweit aus Sicht der
Staatsanwaltschaft
ja guten Tag meine Damen und Herren auch
von meiner Seite ich würde gerne
beginnen indem ich ihn ein paar
Einzelheiten zu den Todesopfern
bei den Todesopfern handelt es sich um
vier Männer und zwei Frauen im Alter von
33 bis 60 Jahren sowie einen weiblichen
Fotos wir haben schon gehört im Alter
von 7 Monaten alle Todesopfer sind
deutscher Staatsangehörigkeit und
das
können wir versuchen
so besser hervorragend dann bei den
Todesopfern handelt sich um vier Männer
und zwei Frauen im Alter zwischen 33 und
60 Jahren sowie den bereits erwähnten
weiblichen Fötus im Alter von 28 Wochen
alle Todesopfer sind deutscher
Staatsangehörigkeit und starben jeweils
durch Schuss Einwirkung darüber hinaus
wurden sechs Frauen und zwei Männer im
Alter zwischen 23 und 46 Jahren verletzt
sechs von ihnen sind deutsche
Staatsangehörige hier eine Frau ist
ugandischer bzw ukrainischer
Staatsangehörigkeit mindestens vier von
ihnen wurden lebensbedrohlich verletzt
teils mit multiplen Schusswunden
dieser Amoklauf wurde von dem
35-Jährigen deutschen Staatsangehörigen
Philipp fangegangen
kriminalpolizeilich wir haben es eben
schon von der Staatsanwaltschaft gehört
ist er bislang nicht als Beschuldigter
in Erscheinung getreten er wurde
ebenfalls tot in der Kirche der Zeugen
Jehovas aufgefunden offensichtlich
richtete er seine Waffe gegen sich
selbst bei eintreffende Einsatzkräfte
bei Philipp FF handelt es sich um ein
ehemaliges Mitglied dieser Gemeinde der
Zeugen Jehovas welches die Gemeinde vor
etwa anderthalb Jahren freiwillig aber
offenbar nicht im guten verlassen hat
einfach offenbar ledig lebte und
arbeitete seit 2014 in Hamburg
Philipp F verfügte über eine
waffenrechtliche Erlaubnis als
Sportschütze und war daher im legalen
Besitz einer Schusswaffe des Typs
Heckler und Koch P30 bei dieser handelt
es sich auch um die Tatwaffe die neben
dem Täter auf dem Boden aufgefunden
wurde
am Tatort wurden insgesamt 9 Lehre
Magazine aufgefunden weitere 20 gefüllte
Magazine für der in einem Rucksack bei
sich zwei Magazine für der Mann in
seiner Wohnung konnten wie bereits
gehört weitere 15 gefüllte Magazine
sowie weitere 200 schussmunition
sichergestellt werden jedes der Magazine
umfasst bis zu 15 Schuss darüber hinaus
haben wir bei der wohnungsdurchführung
entsprechend diverse elektronische
Geräte und schriftliche Unterlagen
sichergestellt
anhand der bisherigen Zeugenaussagen den
aufgefundenen Patronenhülsen und Magazin
und das vorliegenden Bildmaterials ist
davon auszugehen dass Philipp F allein
gehandelt hat das Motiv für die Tat
lässt sich derzeit noch nicht sicher
feststellen hier laufen unsere
Ermittlungen weiter
Anhaltspunkte für eine politische
Motivation der Tat liegt derzeit nicht
vor
vielen Dank
ja meine Damen und Herren ich ergänze
die Frage die sich bei solchen Taten ja
immer stellt ist wie kommen Personen in
den Besitz von Schusswaffen insofern
lassen Sie mich kurz auf diesen Umstand
eingehen zunächst einmal ist da die
bereits erwähnte waffenrechtliche
Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung die bei
Beantragung des
Waffenscheins durch Philipp F erfolgt
ist unter Einbindung der stellen so wie
es vorgesetzt sehen ist
Abfragen aus den polizeilichen
systemabfragen beim Landesamt für
Verfassungsschutz bei einem Staatsschutz
der Polizei und das ist auch hier
erfolgt darüber hinaus
ist unsere Waffenbehörde ein
anonymer Hinweis zugegangen und zwar im
Januar 2023 also diesen Januar
ein hinweisschreiben von einer bis heute
unbekannten Person mit dem Ziel dieses
Ziel ist in dem Schreiben zum Ausdruck
gebracht das Verhalten und die
waffenrechtlichen Vorschriften in Bezug
auf den Philipp F zu überprüfen
die anonyme Person
brachte in dem Schreiben die Auffassung
zum Aufdruck dass der Philip F an einer
psychischen Erkrankung leiden könnte
ohne wie die Person schreibt dass dieses
ärztlich diagnostiziert sei da Philipp F
sich schlicht nicht in ärztliche
Behandlung begeben würde
Philipp F hege eine besondere Wut auf
religiöse Anhänger oder ebenso erwähnt
besonders gegenüber den Zeugen Jehovas
und seinem ehemaligen Arbeitgeber
der eine zeugenschaftliche Vernehmung
des Hinweis gebenden aufgrund der
Anonymität nicht möglich war und der
nahmen die Beamten der Waffenbehörde
weitere Recherchen Recherchen in den
polizeilichen auskunftssystemen die sie
ja schon mal abgefragt hatten aber jetzt
erneut abfrachten und den öffentlich
zugänglichen Quellen bei denen sie
insgesamt keine Informationen erlangten
bis zum heutigen Tag ist ja keine
Registrierung
erfolgt am 7.2 wurde dann der Philipp F
im Rahmen einer unangekündigten
Kontrolle von zwei
Polizeibeamten der Waffenbehörde an
seiner Wohnanschrift in Altona
aufgesucht
jede anonymer jeder anonyme Hinweis und
davon gibt es einige bei der
Waffenbehörde wird standardmäßig mit
einer Kontrolle begegnet das heißt
standardmäßig wird man nimmt man eine
Kontrolle vor
die Besonderheit hier man hat eine
unangekündigte Kontrolle vorgenommen
weil man sich aufgrund des Schreibens
doch
die Situation ohne dass man den Philipp
er vorher quasi vor waren wollte
anschauen wollte bei dieser
unangekündigten Kontrolle wurde Philipp
F angetroffen
er zeigte sich kooperativ erteilte
bereitwillig Auskunft es war ein offenes
Gespräch man hat die waffenrechtlichen
Vorschriften dazu gehört die Verwahrung
der Waffe und der Munition im Tresor
überprüft und die als eingehalten
festgestellt insgesamt gab es bis auf
eine Kleinigkeit bei der ein Projektil
oberhalb der des Tresors lag keinerlei
relevante Beanstandungen die gesamten
Umstände
wiesen auch keinerlei Anhaltspunkte für
die Beamten auf die hätten auf eine
psychische Erkrankung hindeuten können
Gegenteil man hat ein weiteres Gespräch
über verschiedenste Dinge die
Einrichtung der Wohnung und ähnliche
Dinge mit ihm geführt und ist am Ende
des Tages rausgegangen und hat ihm wegen
der von mir erwähnten kleine wegen des
kleinen Verstoßes eine mündliche
Verwarnung erteilt er hat sich
entschuldigt es war ihm erkennbar
peinlich und dieses Projektil wurde auch
sofort im Tresor verschlossen
damit lagen für die vor Ort tätigen
Beamten keine weiteren
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten für
polizeiliche Maßnahmen mehr zugrunde die
Sicherstellung der Waffe nach Paragraph
46 Absatz vier Waffengesetz oder auch
die Beantragung eines
fachpsychologischen Zeugnisses nach
Paragraph 6 Absatz 2 Waffengesetz
verlangen beide Tatsachen und diese
Tatsachen für diese Tatsachen gab es
keine ausreichende rechtliche
Möglichkeit bzw die Rechtsgrundlage lag
nicht vor aber schlecht nur ein anonymes
Schreiben zugrunde lag die rechtlichen
Möglichkeiten der Beamten waren damit
ausgeschöpft
Philipp F war wie gesagt bis zur
gestrigen Tat auch nicht nach wie vor
nicht in polizeilichen Systemen
registriert also auch danach ist sind
keinerlei polizeilichen Vorgänge mehr
bekannt geworden
mit der Abfrage zu Beginn seiner seiner
Beantragung sind also mehrmals abfragen
und Überprüfungen im Zusammenhang mit
den Personalien Philipp F erfolgt
für die er verfügt seit dem 6.12 22 über
diese Waffen besitzkarte die ist eben
erlaubt eine Schusswaffe sowie die
dazugehörige Munition zu erwerben seit
dem 12.12 befand er sich somit im
legalen Besitz einer halbautomatischen
Pistole
dass sie sich dabei um die Tatwaffe
handelt nach aktuellen Stand ist schon
gesagt worden
auch wenn die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Waffenbehörde diesen Hinweis
professionell nachgegangen sind und sich
persönlich von der Situation überzeugt
haben die Überprüfung persönlich
vorgenommen haben
müssen wir diese Abläufe vor allen
Dingen die rechtlichen Abläufe auch die
Voraussetzung für weitere Maßnahmen uns
noch mal kritisch angucken und das tun
wir dabei muss auch geprüft werden ob
die rechtlichen Befugnisse angepasst
werden müssen oder angepasst werden
können und müssen und
weitere Prozesse optimiert werden können
vielen Dank
ich denke es wird Fragen geben wir haben
eine Kollegin oder einen Kollegen mit
einer Angel hier ich habe hier das
kleine Mikrofon das würde ich dann jetzt
hingeben ich darf die Medienvertreter
bitten einmal kurz ihren Namen zu sagen
und das Medium für diese die Fragen
stellen und dann gehen wir dann ein
bisschen anderes haben Frage gestellt
werden
okay dann fangen wir mal an dass der
erste ist hier vorne ja sowas habe ich
glaube ich gesehen unter der Maske
was
und du was von der Bild-Zeitung ich habe
eine Frage
herr Meier was ihre letzten Ausführung
angeht sie sagt ja dann sind zahlreiche
Überprüfungen vorgenommen worden sind
ihnen denn Erkenntnisse in diesem Zuge
überliefert worden dass es von dem
früheren Wohnsitz in Bayern der hat dort
studiert in München an einer Hochschule
Hinweise auf Drogen Missbrauch in der
Vergangenheit gegeben hat die wohl
polizeilich in bayerischen
polarsystemen vermerkt gewesen sind
nein das kann nicht verneinen der alte
der Hinweise lagen uns nicht vor wie
gesagt ob sie uns hätten erlangen können
oder müssen gehört für mich zu der
Überprüfung des gesamten Sachverhaltes
im Hinblick auf
Optimierungsmöglichkeiten
Martin Fischer von der dpa mich würde
interessieren auf welcher Grundlage
diese waffenrechtliche Erlaubnis
beantragt wurde war er sportschütz warum
hat es sich da gehandelt und gibt es
schon einen ersten Überblick wie viel
Schüsse er in dem Gebäude abgegeben hat
sie sagten auf dem Parkplatz schon ob
das Auto allein zehn Einschusslöcher
ja soweit oder macht das
ja das kann ich beantworten insgesamt
hat er neun Magazine A15 Schuss
verschossen und in den Waffenbesitz ist
er tatsächlich als Sportschütze gelangt
[Musik]
von der dpa können Sie zu den Opfern
noch mal genau sagen wer wie alt war sie
haben nur so summarisch gesagt 33 bis
etwas über 60
[Musik]
und lassen Sie mich den passenden Zettel
raussuchen
da haben wir einmal eine Frau im Alter
von 23 Jahren
ein Mann im Alter von
33 Jahren ein Mann im Alter von
66 Jahren ein Mann im Alter von
Entschuldigung bitte eine Frau im Alter
von
33 Jahren
ein Mann im Alter von 32 Jahren eine
Frau im Alter von
[Musik]
27 Jahren eine Frau im Alter von 23
Jahren und noch eine Frau im Alter von
noch mal 33 Jahren die Todesopfer haben
die zwei Personen das Geburtsjahr 83
sind also 40 Jahre alt eine Person
68er Baujahr eine Person 63er Baujahr
eine Person 82er und eine 89er Baujahr
und dann den Embryo